you hear these stories and you say okay  at least his father whether you want to  call it stepfather or not he was  committed to wanting to raise the  leaders you have to love raising leaders  if that's not something that you value  and it's not a dream of yours don't have  kids but you know the Jewish proverb  says there's three things every man  should do okay plant a tree  write a book have a son okay because all  those three outlive you when you write a  book if you write a good book people are  going to read it when you're dead when  you plant a tree if you do it right it's  going to outlive you when you have a son  it's going to outlive you and your  legacy continues so it's a very  different Dynamic  um you officially are in two places at  the same time it's where you are and  it's wherever your kid is at if you got  two kids three different places at the  same time you're always thinking but  it's a different Dynamic that's for sure